porque están aquí porque estoy aquí por
la vida la vida es una oportunidad que
nos brinda
muchas experiencias vividas aquellas
personas que realmente me encanta la
belleza todo el bello todo el lindo el
poder aprender el poder saber el poder
saber unirse para orientar su vida es el
don especial de la educación por eso
educar es una misión tan noble que
solamente una persona con vocación puede
transmitir conocimientos habilidades y
destrezas a niños adolescentes a jóvenes
y más en adultos a aquellos que no han
tenido la oportunidad de acercarse a un
centro educativo
la educación hoy es desde los padres la
familia educa la escuela enseña por eso
los padres que les ha gran visión de
traer una criatura al mundo y encargados
primero de la educación de sus hijos
después concurren a la escuela donde la
escuela le enseña la enseña a
desarrollar valores que ya tenemos cada
uno impreso en nuestra vida
valores que van saliendo a medida que
uno va creciendo la vida es dinámica no
es estática cuando nosotros éramos
chicos mirábamos un mundo muy lejano
cuando éramos jóvenes creíamos que
sabíamos todo y cuando llegamos a la
vida adulta
pensamos aquello que no entendían ahora
ya no estoy entendiendo y cuál es el
factor más importante de la enseñanza la
lectura es leer la persona que logra
leer récord del mundo desde en su casa
aprende
atiende a la diversidad que nos ha dado
la naturaleza y así puede completar ese
plano importante de no solamente en
sacar el saber certificado sino tener
una gran experiencia de la vida y poder
tener la gran capacidad de transmitirlo
a los demás
me llevó a ser maestro una vocación o
entrega total no solamente a preparar
las clases sino a acompañar
especialmente a aquellas personas que
tenían dificultad de aprendizaje
y los logros muchísimos recuerdo una vez
una pequeña anécdota un padre llevó a su
hijo en quinto grado y me dice nos hemos
trasladado del campo pero nosotros
queríamos que viniera estudiar y
y dije bueno vamos a ver qué se puede
hacer y empezamos a tener una relación
muy estrecha que no solamente mira al
alumno sino ponerle la mano en el hombro
creando una confianza el chico del
primer día de la clase fue a la casa de
ser
estoy contento y la madre que dice
porque estás contento nunca ministrers
es así de la escuela el maestro me
escuchó
fíjese importante para mí en la historia
del maestro de recordar ese hecho hoy es
un psicólogo una profesión noble y está
ejerciendo
muchas anécdotas se pueden decir pero
especialmente aquellas que nos enseñan a
escuchar
y admirar pero no mirar solamente con
nuestros ojos sino observar dónde están
los detalles importantes
la vida me fue llevando de un lugar a
otro de un lugar a otro social y casi la
última parte de mi vida de los 67 años
que tengo a la acción social concreta
después de haber caminado casi dos meses
las calles de la ciudad y de tener
contacto directa con la gente vi que
necesitaban un comedor alguien que les
prepare la comida y nomás un grupo de
voluntarios comenzamos una tarea de
darle de comer a la gente de la calle en
situación de calle de noche cuando
caminaba por las calles vi que un hombre
se metía entre la seguridad y buscaba
algo de comer en los tachos
despacito me acerqué y digo que ando
haciendo un hombre y con las lágrimas en
los ojos me dice ando buscando comida
porque te digo tengo cinco hijos y no me
alcanza la plata así que junto a todas
las noches y algo llevo para la casa
bueno mire
mañana nos encontramos en tal lugar le
di la dirección al otro día viene y la
señora y dice nos va a dar de comer si
hasta el día de hoy todos los días a
buscar comida pero algo importante no
solamente buscar comida sino que limpia
vívidas y barre veredas
un trapo de piso una escoba me sacó de
la pobreza de colombres con lágrimas en
el ojo en los ojos y diciendo que
interesante que es poder comunicar lo
que yo sentía dentro a otra persona que
me escuchó hoy los insto a ustedes que
estamos escuchando que no tengan miedo
no hay que preocuparse por pobres hay
que ocuparse de los pobres buscando
siempre la promoción no dar sino también
enseñar no le demos el peso enseñemos lo
aplicar
es fácil hay que tener un corazón fuerte
muchas ganas de acercarse para escuchar
a las personas muchas ganas de ir a
visitar las personas uno descubre un
mundo que muchas veces no responde a
nuestra cultura pero si es diferente a
las necesidades estar siempre presentes
no nos podemos ausentar no podemos decir
a mí no me corresponde todos tenemos
algo para dar y ese algo para dar es
primero la capacidad de escucha segundo
poder observar
después todo aparece
cuántas veces no hemos tenido comida
para dar a la gente pero confiamos la
providencia siempre aparece gente buena
con la gran con gran calidad que nos
ayuda a partir del pan y si una parte
del pan con la comida baja la violencia
y es cierto el hombre es violento cuando
tienen necesidades que no puede
satisfacer pero el hombre también no
solamente con el plato de comida vemos
necesario dar la escolaridad primaria a
aquellas personas adultas que no han
terminado la escuela y es importante que
un hombre sacado debajo una planta pasar
por una pieza terminó el primario
terminó el secundario y hoy está
haciendo taller de memoria 64 años de
edad del que se puede hay que tener
fuerza coraje
es decir que el otro puedo poder haber
sido yo como bebé sin tratarse por eso
miremos siempre que al lado nuestro hay
alguien que necesita pero aquí está
porque dando se recibe cuando nosotros
damos también recibimos y recibimos
sonrisas recibimos que mandan los chicos
a la escuela recibimos que los chicos
están limpios recibimos que la casa está
limpia y ordenada
cuántas cosas podemos hacer esto me
viene a la memoria la historia del
colibrí el colibrí es un pajarito muy
pequeño pero una vez sensación el bosque
y todos los animales fluyeron y el
colibrí con su piquito fue llevando una
gotita de agua
para apagar el incendio los otros
animales de decían pero como es posible
con esa gotita de agua insignificante y
el colibrí dice que le dice yo hago lo
que puedo
por eso cada uno puede hacer algo por
esta sociedad porque la vamos a
solucionar entre todos empezando por
nuestras casas las casas la familia en
la primera célula de la familia esa
sociedad que necesita familias
conformadas familias altruistas que
maten el egoísmo que tenemos por eso la
vida la vida vale la pena gracias
[Aplausos]